revisiting sandman like
you know which is about the world going
mad in its own way
it hits in a different way right now
it's very weird
in that sandman
was uh you know i started writing it
33 34 years ago
and it was very much
of its time as far as i was concerned i
was
i wasn't trying to create something for
the ages
i was trying to create something that
was about what i was concerned with
at that time and
yet it seems to have
lasted so much better than i would have
imagined
um and it seems to speak to us sometimes
from 33 years ago and to have opinions
on things that
are very now and
i
i i find that
peculiar and
occasionally prescient and sometimes i
want to go back in time and go okay well
i think
you know young neil was a radio
tuned to interesting stations
um but mostly i just think that i
you know it was
sometimes the world takes a while to
catch up with things
and um i think there are definitely
places where
stuff that we were writing about stuff i
was writing about
people were drawing 30 something years
ago
um i may not have got it exactly right
but i was definitely talking about the
things that we're concerned with now
you know is a perfect segue of course
you're talking about how
the audible adaptation came around uh
because you know what was what was kind
of the genesis of the project
uh the genesis the project is 1992.
when uh a young bbc
producer director writer named dirk mags
did his adaptation of the death of
superman for the radio
in the uk and
uh he
it was a huge hit and he was asked what
he wanted to do next
and he said well sandman and
he got in touch with me i loved the idea
we corresponded
and the bbc said absolutely not
and so that was where this began
and neither of us forgot and in later
years you know we got to work together
we got to do stuff on the
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy i
played the voice of the book
um we did um
the um
[Music]
neverwhere good omens
stardust and antsy boys
uh how the marquee got his coat back we
you know things we did and had a
wonderful time doing
for the bbc and then when dirk went on
to audible
um i
honestly don't remember which of us
came up with the idea of
doing sandman for audible
probably dirk but we'd been talking
about it by that point for 28 years
just the idea of how to do it and i
think also
what became very interesting
was
just the idea for me that this
could be the audiobook we've never been
able to have
um it had always seemed
sad and frustrating
that people would come up to me and say
i'm visually impaired i'm blind or i
cannot see
whatever and i would like to read
sandman
is there a way of are there any audio
books for the graphic novels and i would
have to say well
no there really aren't um
and one reason why there aren't is
because you can't just have somebody
sitting in a studio on their own
and reading a script that will give you
the equivalent
experience of reading a graphic novel
so we have here graphic novels
that tens of millions of people
have been able to read all over the
world and i love the idea that
they're getting opened to a whole new
audience they're getting open to an
audience of people
who are visually impaired they're
getting opened to an audience of people
who
cannot or will not or do not have the
kind of brains that process
comic books they're getting
open to an audience of people who know
that they love neil gaiman stuff
but had heard that sandman existed but
never really knew where to start or how
um so for all of those people
we're giving them sandman we're giving
it pretty much
as it was created we're not trying to
change it we're not trying to fix it
whereas for the netflix series there's
definitely the intention that we're
going okay well
if this were now
um if i was creating sandman now
would i have done that thing would i've
written that probably not
with this character been that gender
probably not
how would i have done that i probably
would have done that differently so
letting us
do some of that stuff now and just
enjoying ourselves
that's wonderful yeah i mean i can you
know i've
listened to the first eight chapters and
then i pulled out from my library
uh i was in nocturnes and i was
it was really fascinating to compare the
two because
you're completely correct like it does
it does feel like a very
faithful adaptation and but there's also
just moments where it's like you know
you have
two minutes of description in the audio
in in the audio version for a just a two
page
two pages splash absolutely well what
was lovely with those
is i was able to find all my original
scripts
for the artists so i could give the
scripts to dirk and he could go and
actually lift the
what i wrote for artists
and summarize that
or take actual lines that i'd written
for a specific artist to describe
something for them
and that's lovely just because that's a
part of the process that most audiences
never get to
get to experience with comics absolutely
um in terms of in terms of that
i feel like all writers have you know i
mean you've kind of touched on this
already but
all writers look back on their earl you
know their early writing and
you know sometimes it's with some level
of you know oh goodness i
ha why why did i write that that way was
it
you know not only are you reading this
but a lot of times you're
you're saying you know writing from
several years ago like
how was that experience for you
sandman was harder the first eight
issues of sandman were probably harder
for me while i was writing
the last eight issues i would look at
them and go oh my gosh i was
so clunky back then and look how much
better i am now
whereas now i can just look back at the
whole thing
and go you know
baby neil who wrote it had an awful lot
to learn
but he did a lot right and
look at him trying all this stuff out
and trying to figure out who he is since
like watching
you know watching you when you were a
teenager putting on hats and glasses and
different styles and changing your hair
around
just sort of going who am i what do i
look like um
you know i i love looking at those first
sandmans and i can go okay well the
first one
i'm doing this and then the second one
i'm doing you know ec
comics and i'm doing all of this stuff
and by the third one
i'm doing contemporary urban horror and
by the fourth
i'm trying to do a sort of the thing
that john w
campbell did in unknown magazine in
the 1940s and then by you know
episodes five six and seven i'm trying a
sort of superhero fantasia
that is still hard-edged horror and goes
as dark as it can go and then basically
after that i'm
pretty much done actually with horror um
i'm like i've gone okay well that was
really interesting what else can i do
and now i'm gonna go off and do
a you know here i am in
africa 10 000 years ago and
creating a a tale
and a character and here i am doing the
doll's house and now i'm going to go off
and do season of mess
and there's a level on which i became
technically more skillful but i also
found out for myself what i
what kind of a writer i was and what i
could do and i didn't know
so i
you know i i
don't ever wind up looking at any of
this
as something where i go oh now is my
chance to fix this thing
that you screwed up um
i definitely know that there are things
that if i were
doing them now i would not do them like
that
um but then i also think you have to be
allowed to make mistakes
because if you don't make mistakes you
don't do anything
well i said um you know in your talk you
mentioned this already uh you are having
that
kind of experience a little bit with the
netflix show and
i'm curious like in general how how
has doing this this you know being
involved with this project
influenced what you're doing with uh
with the netflix series
it's been a really nice kind of
control i suppose
in a scientific experiment this would be
the control
it's like okay here's the one where
we're not going to change
anything we're going to adapt it but
we're going to keep it the same
and which allows us in
netflix actually you know alan heinberg
and david goyer and i will have
conversations
where i can actually say oh okay
now if you want to do that now this is
we've done that
in the audible version and this is how
it works
but i think maybe we could actually take
it over here or maybe we could do this
and um
[Music]
and it's very liberating actually having
having one that is the pure control
then means that we sort of know
where the doors are open in netflix and
where we can go okay well
this character is male uh in the
original is there
any particular reason why this character
has to be male
oh there is no point at which this
character you know desperately needs to
use
their penis to stir tea or something
therefore
we have that as a place where we can
good okay well then let's let's change
that
and see you know and you just get to
sort of start
playing and then that takes you to
really interesting places too
you know do you feel like by the end of
the process the netflix show is going to
be
pretty substantially different from the
original comics
yes and no um
i think that if you are somebody who
loves the original comics you will love
the netflix series and i think if you
are somebody
who knows the original comics well
you will have an absolute advantage
plot-wise
in the netflix series um
but much like something like game of
thrones
while you will have an advantage you
will not always be one step ahead
you will have an advantage but
there may well be places where we go and
do something that you are really not
expecting
or where we go and go okay well that was
how we did it we've already done that
what would happen if we if we did this
instead
um and and that i think is also part of
the nature of the beast one of the
things that we've got in
the audible show
is
we have no time limits we have no
constraints
each episode is as long as it needs to
be
to do everything and they mostly come in
around half an hour
maybe a little bit less and
that's what they are um
with netflix we're looking at longer
episodes
so more stuff can happen and if more
stuffs happens then
what would that stuff be and
if you know we we're starting here and
we need to get over to there and we're
still starting here and we still need to
get over there
but wouldn't it be interesting if this
went wrong on the way and that changed
and
this person didn't do this thing and
plus we created this and then we also
had this
plot going on in the background which is
obviously still going on in the
background in the original sandman but
we never actually really
talk about it and you don't know how
they got there but let's go and
let's go and stop in on that and watch
what happens
math nerd in me is just like you know
thinking about how
you've got if 10 episodes of a netflix
show so
probably you know that's 10 hours the
audiobook adaptation
is you know the if it's the first the
first volume is essentially
three and three hours 45 minutes or so
um you know that's a very different
that's a very big difference that's like
almost seven hours of extra material
it's true it's not actually it's not
quite that because
um net the way that we're doing netflix
is the first
season is going to be preludes and
nocturnes and the doll's house
okay oh wow so they will
they they are so it's 10 episodes
which will contain uh
16 of the comics
um but there are and there will be
surprises on the way
the casting on the in the audible
version is fantastic
uh how much is it influencing your
thinking when it comes to casting the
series and i'm
very specifically going to call out um
oh got kat dennings
as uh as death because she's simply
marvelous
and now she's wonderful yes and i'm
having a really hard time not thinking
about her as death
in the live-action version she would be
marvelous
we're right in the middle of the casting
process and
it is a glorious
maddening delightful
fabulous as as all casting processes are
um you know i i
all i all i would ever want in the world
i think for global peace and harmony to
happen
is for everybody who has ever had an
opinion about casting
to have to cast something and
to discover that it just isn't as easy
as you know i've talked to people and
they're like why didn't you cast sound
sir and i'm like well
so-and-so was the first person that we
talked to but they either wanted too
much money
or they weren't available or they didn't
want to do it
or they had something else that
conflicted with it or whatever and
and people like ah but what about
so-and-so and say yeah
no unfortunately so and so
and you you you wind up explaining why
you can't
why people's casting dreams don't
actually happen
and yes you're out there trying to make
casting dreams happen
um the joy
of doing audio is very often
you can make casting dreams happen and
you can make casting dreams happen
because you're actually only asking
somebody to give up
a day or three days
um your asking somebody to give up an
afternoon and come into a studio
and lots of people can find an afternoon
for you
and you know michael sheen is lucifer
i michael sheen is amazing michael sheen
as lucifer michael sheen as david bowie
as lucifer
is astonishing he's wonderful um
he's way way way outside of what audible
ought to be able to afford
as an actor but
michael did it because he loves sir man
and he's a friend and he wants this
thing to happen he wants it to be great
and he wants to be part of it
so and he could find an afternoon to
come in and be lucifer
and we could make that work um
you know casting michael sheen in the
real world is something you have to
start planning
several years ahead of time and you have
to put all the pieces
in to play in order to make everything
work because
there are very few more in demand actors
on the face of the planet
than michael sheen and the odds are very
good that michael sheen will not be
lucifer
um whether we wanted michael sheena's
lucifer
on the tv or not getting
somebody of that stature available when
you need them
is really difficult so
the all of the casting that we did
on audible informs
what we're doing on the tv
um and in fact ways of
but it but it's also they are their own
things
you know and there are places where that
character may not be that thing anymore
well um i'll make this my last question
okay
and then i think basically it just kind
of comes down to
um i remember talking to you a year ago
for good elements and one of the things
you said about that experience was that
you were hoping it would help people
understand that sometimes you can just
trust your material
and let it be itself and
this is basically a follow-up how it's
been over a year uh you're working on
this now
you're working on sandman now you're
probably working on a couple of other
things that we don't know about
uh uh has that panned out has that been
the case
i think good omens was was fascinating
for me because it came out
to a deafening silence except that
people watched it and loved it all over
the world and it got these amazing
viewing figures
but it almost felt like it might never
have not have come out for all the
attention it was getting
and then slowly i would start running
into people who would go hey i saw good
omens it was on my
amazon prime and i had it i i didn't
know it was it was wonderful
and then it started getting awards
nominations and then it started winning
things
and now it's being
you know i and now it is beloved
and people are very willing to say oh
yes
and it was interesting when all of the
promo over here
for staged came out i don't know if you
got to see that
with um it's a wonderful show it's it's
david tennant and michael sheen in
lockdown playing essentially versions of
themselves
working on a play and it's hilarious and
they are so funny
and um
and all of the reviews and articles on
that are sort of like ah
you know having crushed the world on
good omens
they come together on and i loved that
um i
definitely felt like having made good
omens
gave me the chops
and the technical authority as well as
the moral authority to be able to talk
about
particularly sandman um
but it's been really good you know
talking with with alan heinberg
in particular who's show running sandman
you know the fact that i now speak
fluent showrunner
is incredibly useful but that i also
speak fluent sandman still
and i can
and i can look at a script and go this
is fabulous and
what if we did this that and the other
to it
what would that do and um
and watch him getting all excited and
he's really all excited just because
it's it all feels like sound man
again thank you for your time today it's
been a real pleasure
you are so welcome it was enormously fun